I'm so many weaknesses it you know I
don't we could fill up the next hundred
episodes of daily beady rock with my
weaknesses I just think one of them
interesting things about how I roll is
how little I focus on the weaknesses
it's funny I'm so focused on my
strengths I'm so focused on the
opportunities at hand I'm so focused on
the positivity the optimism of the game
I'm just not really good at respecting
my weaknesses I'm not good at dwelling
at my weaknesses I'm not good at
acknowledging my weaknesses why
everybody else is doing that for you
understand that understand that 90% the
world's trying to focus on your
weaknesses I'm watching the basketball
stuff right now they're focusing on
Steph Curry's weaknesses LeBron's
weaknesses draymond some weaknesses
everybody's got weaknesses I think to
win you need to be your biggest fan you
need to focus on strengths
Oh
this is a real part of me that cuts that
cancer out like we've all got it
we've all got overuses everybody I just
think the people that win respect their
strengths more